.
AND THERE'S A CLEAR LINK BETWEEN
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
WE LOOK AT WHAT'S CAUSING THE
MOST DAMAGE.
>>> THE U.S. IS TRYING TO BOTH
DE-ESCALATE THE SITUATION AND
SHORE UP UKRAINE'S DEFENSES.
FOR THE PAST FEW WEEKS RUSSIA
HAS BUILT UP TROOPS AND MILITARY
HARDWARE NEAR UKRAINE'S BOARDER
AND UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS SAY MOSCOW HAS BEEN
CONDUCTING LARGE-SCALE MILITARY
EXERCISES IN THE SEPARATIST
CONTROLLED EASTERN REGIONS.
THE U.S. IS NOW CONSIDERING
SENDING MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE,
INCLUDING ADVISERS, EQUIPMENT,
AND MACHINERY.
RUSSIA CLAIMS THE U.S. IS
ALREADY DOING THAT, AND IT'S
ONLY AGGRAVATING TENSIONS.
TODAY THE U.S. AND RUSSIA'S TOP
GENERALS SPOKE BY PHONE TO
DISCUSS SEVERAL SECURITY ISSUES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY SAID ON
THE CALL, BUT THE KREMLIN
SPOKESPERSON SAYS RUSSIA HAS NO
PLANS TO CROSS UKRAINE'S
BORDERS.
CNN'S SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT FRED PLEITGEN IS
IN -- TO TELL US HOW UKRAINE IS
PREPARING FOR THE POSSIBLE
THREAT.
UKRAINE HAS THE MOST ALARMIST
ASSESSMENT OF RUSSIA'S
INTENTIONS.
THEIR SECURITY AGENCY THINKS AN
INVASION IS COMING NEXT YEAR.
IS THAT WARRANTED, AND HOW ARE
THEY PREPARING?
>> Reporter: THEY CERTAINLY
BELIEVE AN INVASION COULD COME
THE BEGIN OF NEXT YEAR, AND IT
IS SOMETHING THEY ARE PREPARING
FOR.
ON THE ONE HAND, OF COURSE, THEY
DO WANT INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT.
THEY WANT TO SUPPORT OF THE U.S.
AND ITS ALLIES BUT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE ALSO SAYING
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BACK DOWN,
THEY'RE GOING TO STAND THEIR
GROUND.
ON THE ONE HAND THEY'RE
MODERNIZING THEIR MILITARY, BUT
IMPROVING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S GOING TO BE KEY IN THE
EAST OF THE COULD YOU REPEAT.
COUNTRY.
HERE'S WHAT WE SAW.
ON PATROL IN SOME OF THE MOST
CONTESTED WATERS IN THE WORLD.
UKRAINE'S NAVY TOOK US ON A
MILITARY BOAT IN THE SEA JUST AS
TENSIONS WITH RUSSIA REACHED A
BOILING POINT.
OUR MAIN GOAL IS TO DEFEND AND
KEEP THE SOVEREIGNTY OF UKRAINE
FROM THE DIRECTION OF THE SEA,
THE CAPTAIN TELLS ME.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN AMASSING TROOPS
NEAR UKRAINE'S BORDERS, WARNING
ALLIES A LARGE-SCALE INVASION
COULD HAPPEN SOON.
THE UKRAINIANS BELIEVE IF RUSSIA
DOES DECIDE TO LAUNCH AN ATTACK,
THIS SEA COULD BE ONE OF THE
BATTLEGROUNDS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE MODERNIZING
THEIR FLEET BUT ALSO THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE ON LAND AS WELL.
THE COASTLINE HOLDS STRATEGIC
VALUE TO RUSSIA.
IT WOULD ALLOW VLADIMIR PUTIN TO
ESTABLISH A MUCH SOUGHT LAND
CORRIDOR TO CONNECT RUSSIA TO
ANNEXED CRIMEA.
UKRAINE'S DEFENSE MINISTRY GAVE
US ACCESS TO THE CONSTRUCTION
GOING ON AT THIS NAVAL BASE.
KIEV ORDERED THIS BUILDING
PROGRAM TO BE ACCELERATED WITH
THE RUSSIAN THREAT LOOMING
LARGE.
IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THIS
PROJECT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE,
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY TELLS US
THEY ARE WORKING SEVEN DAY A
WEEK, AND THEY SAY ONCE IT'S
FINISHED IT WILL OFFER A
FORMIDABLE DETERRENT AGAINST
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION.
UPGRADES SEEM IN DIRE NEED.
UKRAINE SAYS NEW FACILITIES WILL
ALLOW THEM THE BASE MORE AND
BIGGER SHIPS HERE.
WE ARE READY, THIS OFFICER SAYS.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE HERE, SO THAT
AT AT ANY TIME IF THERE IS ANY
AGGRESSION IN THE SEA, WE CAN
RESIST IT.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT SAYS RUSSIA
POSITIONED CLOSE TO 100,000
TROOPS NEAR ITS BORDERS, WHICH
THE KREMLIN DENIES.
THESE SATELLITE IMAGES,
APPEARING TO SHOW DOZENS OF
MILITARY VEHICLES IN
SOUTHWESTERN RUSSIA.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WARNED
MOSCOW NOT TO ATTACK AND IS
MULLING MORE WEAPONS DELIVERIES
TO KIEV.
CNN LEARNED ONE U.S. DEFENSE
OFFICIAL SAYS RUSSIA'S AIM MAY
BE TO CREATE CONFUSSING OR GET
CONCESSIONS.
THE KREMLIN DISMISSED TALK OF AN
INVASION AS HYSTERIA, BUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN ISSUED A CLEAR
WARNING.
>> Translator: WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THAT WESTERN PARTNERS
WORSEN THE SITUATION BY
DELIVERING TO KIEV MODERN LETHAL
WEAPONS AND PROVOCATIVE ACTIONS
IN THE SEA, NOT ONLY THERE, BUT
OTHER PLACES CLOSE TO OUR
BORDERS.
>> Reporter: UKRAINE'S ARMED
FORCES SAY THEY ARE ON CONSTANT
ALERT, PREPARING FOR AN ARMED
CONFRONTATION THEY HOPE CAN BE
AVOIDED.
BIANCA, THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY
CONDUCTED SOME AIR FORCE
EXERCISES OF THEIR OWN TODAY AND
THE OTHER THING, THEY ALSO DREW
UP A NEW LAW THAT WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM IN THE FUTURE TO
DRAW UP TO 200,000 RESERVISTS
SHOULD THINGS GET WORSE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT IS SOMETHING
EVERYBODY HERE IS TRYING THE
AVOID AND THEY HOPE THIS
CONFLICT HERE DOES NOT ESCALATE.
BIANCA?
>> FRED, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
POSTURING THAT WE'RE SEEING?
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS RUSSIA
TRYING TO TEST THE WEST'S
RESOLVE IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WOULD MILITARILY
INTERVENE IF UKRAINE WAS UNDER
THREAT FROM RUSSIA?
WE HEAR A LOT RHETORICALLY FROM
BIDEN AND THE WEST ABOUT IN
SUPPORT OF UKRAINE, BUT THERE IS
THIS BIG QUESTION MARK AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY BACK IT UP IN TERMS OF
MILITARY SUPPORT.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
WELL, I THINK THAT CERTAINLY IS
A VERY BIG QUESTION MARK, AND I
THINK THE UKRAINIANS ALSO FEEL
THAT AS WELL, IF THINGS DO -- IF
BAD DOES COME TO WORSE HERE, AND
THERE IS SOME SORT OF MILITARY
CONFLICT OR ESCALATION OR
INVASION THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO
PROBABLY FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
MOST POSSIBLY WITH NEW U.S.
WEAPONS THEY COULD POSSIBLY
EMPLOY.
BUT IN THE END, THE UKRAINIANS,
YOU DO FEEL THEY'RE TRYING TO
BUILD UP THE MILITARY, MODERNIZE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHETHER THAT'S POSTURING OR NOT,
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A REAL
THREAT THAT'S THERE OR A
MILITARY BUILDUP, THAT MIGHT,
LIKE WE'VE SEEN AT THE BEGIN OF
THE YEAR, GO AWAY OR RUSSIANS
WITHDRAW THE FORCES, IT IS
DIFFICULT TO SAY.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS WE ARE
FEELING ON THE GROUND, WE'RE
HEARING FROM OFFICIALS ABOUT
GROUND AND OFFICIALS IN THE U.S.
AS WELL, THEY ARE TAKING THIS
VERY SERIOUSLY.
THEY DO BELIEVE THE THREAT IS
VERY SERIOUS, AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY YOU'RE
SEEING SO MUCH PUBLIC MESSAGING
ON THE PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ALSO
WARNING THE U.S.'S ALLIES THIS
IS SOMETHING THEY NEED TAKE
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY, AND OF
COURSE ALSO, SOME HIGH LEVEL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE RUSSIANS
AS WELL.
LIKE FOR INSTANCE TODAY WHEN THE
U.S. CHIEF OF STAFF TALKED TO
THE GENERAL CHIEF OF STAFF OF
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY TODAY, THE
U.S. TRYING TO DRIVE HOME TO
POINT TO THE RUSSIANS -- DO NOT
ATTACK UKRAINE.
THE U.S., OF COURSE, WILL BE ON
UKRAINE ANSWER SIDE.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT MEANS
INTERVENING MILITARILY, OF
COURSE, THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
SOMETHING UKRAINIANS ARE GOI